this video is brought to you by mubi get
30 days for free by going to movie.com
now you see it is it possible
the two utes the two what
there's no better test for a filmmaker
than the courtroom scene think about
everything going on in a courtroom scene
while a lawyer interrogates a witness
the judge moderates the examination the
other lawyer potentially objects and the
witness answers the questions
that's already a handful of people and
that doesn't even include all the
spectators
the accused the jury and all the people
watching there's so much going on that
some films decide to just simplify the
scene in the first trial seen in a few
good men we get introduced to the jury
and
the victim's family in the audience but
after that those characters don't get
any more screen time
and stay in the background for the rest
of the movie this choice makes sense for
the film because it's based on a play
and that play didn't even have a jury or
spectators on stage
in plays the viewer watches from one
angle so there isn't as much space as an
actual courtroom but film doesn't have
that limitation
the camera can be anywhere at any time
capturing moments from all the
characters within a huge courtroom
the courtroom scenes in a few good men
focus on only a few characters
and they're very well shot but i don't
think they show the full potential of a
courtroom scene
with so many different perspectives to
play up a courtroom can raise the stakes
for many characters at once which can
create some of the most complicated and
satisfying scenes in cinema
many films manage to pull off this
narrative complexity giving each
character their own moments while still
maintaining spatial and editorial
clarity so how do they do it
the answer depends on the film but one
thing is always clear a well-shot
courtroom scene requires a mastery of
several cinematic techniques so let's
take this video to court
all right all right all right
the space of the courtroom itself
presents a challenge for the filmmaker a
typical scene with dialogue will follow
the 180 rule this rule means that the
camera stays on one side of two
characters to keep the shot spatially
consistent
some films purposefully break this rule
to create disorientation like in the
bathroom scene in the shining the camera
crosses that imaginary line and the
angle change makes the scene feel more
uneasy and dreamlike but in a scene with
more characters breaking the 180 rule
can confuse the audience did you and mr
kimball travel to washington dc
this scene repeatedly breaks the rule in
confusing ways moving around the court
without giving any sense of the space
the jury and spectators might as well be
in different rooms but the problem is
that a large scene like this one has to
break the rule because it's impossible
to show the entire 360 degree space
if you're stuck on one side so how do
you break the rule without confusing the
audience
let's say you want to introduce a new
character in a spot the audience hasn't
seen yet how do you do it
first use blocking in this scene in a
bug's life hopper crosses the imaginary
line by moving from the right of the
frame to the left
by changing sides he comfortably moves
the imaginary line to a new position
that will later include the new
character
plus it has the added effect of making
hopper appear in control of the scene
his movement literally controls the
camera you can also use framing we don't
know it yet but the new character shows
up in the cave entrance that's now
on the right side of this shot placing
hopper on the left side of the frame
balances the camera move to the right
finally cement this new position by
having the entire colony look from left
to right
this blocking sets up the payoff while
also further reinforcing the new
imaginary line
one of the layout artists for the film
said this was a challenging scene to
pull off because moving the line
required careful choreography and
framing and when it works we don't even
notice it this isn't a courtroom scene
but it functions exactly like one
there's a crowd of spectators
main action in the center and it even
has a surprise witness
what i'm trying to say is that all
courtroom scenes have the same challenge
as this one-off scene in a bug's life
the massive space of a courtroom packed
with all its different characters
means that any coherent courtroom scene
requires the same laser precision from
this particularly complicated scene
to kill a mockingbird uses the same 180
rule transitioning as a bug's life
at first the camera's on one side but
atticus crosses the line to move the
camera to the opposite side
his blocking prepares us for the camera
change so it feels natural
and like hopper it has the same
subconscious effect of showing atticus's
command
of the scene the editing also prepares
the viewer for new angles of the
courtroom the camera starts close
between atticus and mayella but once she
accuses tom
the camera moves to him ending the back
and forth and moving the imaginary line
again
this small change allows the camera to
include tom in the scene and
naturally transition to a new back and
forth between tom and atticus
in many ways a courtroom scene is a
collection of smaller scenes and the
right editing and blocking can
transition from one mini scene to
another
every time a main character talks to a
new character the filmmaker needs to set
up a new spatial relationship
like when a lawyer goes from questioning
a witness to talking to a judge
and one way to make this change is by
moving the camera oh
what was that word uh what word
to what what these individual techniques
may seem simple on their own but when
combined the audience gets a full
understanding of the courtroom while
only being able to see a small portion
of it at any given time
along with planning out the proper
angles for the camera a filmmaker also
has to plan what the shots will actually
look like
some of the most iconic courtroom
moments in film do come from close-ups
that show an intense performance but i
think the most
interesting shots are the ones that take
advantage of the full space of the
courtroom
when atticus questions mayella the
background mostly shows the white
audience but when he continues with tom
the shots add the black audience on the
second floor into the frame
because the geography of a courtroom is
so well understood
there's plenty of opportunity to frame
other characters in the shot to create a
more dynamic image
what is a ute oh excuse me
honor two youths you're watching the
lawyers but if you actually think to
look or do look there's almost this out
of focus
expression in the background which i
think in a way is more effective and
more moving because
it does make you project a lot onto them
of what you think
they must be feeling or thinking a few
could meant does have similar frame
composition
but because the drama mainly focuses on
the emotions of just
two people at once the framing doesn't
have the same emotional projection that
happens in other courtroom scenes
the focus on two characters emphasizes
the drama of the main interaction but it
comes at the expense
of not always creating a strong spatial
and emotional understanding of the
courtroom
which means not always spending the time
setting up transitions or moving the
camera to change focus
in that film the camera focuses on
keeping the story moving not necessarily
to capture the emotions of all the
characters in the courtroom but for many
courtroom movies it's crucial to get
that full experience right from the
beginning which is why one of the most
effective tools for the courtroom
is the crane shot crane shots are
perfect for a courtroom scene many
scenes start with a wide shot and then
use the crane to move into the action by
transitioning from an establishing shot
to a medium shot in a single take
the audience gets a very clear
understanding of the space and no
courtroom drama takes the crane shot
further than the show that people vs o.j
simpson american crime story the
cinematic style of this show directly
contrasts how people actually watch the
oj trial in real life the live tv
broadcast came from only one camera
mounted in the corner of the courtroom
the tv dramatization instead uses the
crane shot extensively to give the
viewer an up-close experience of the
entire trial the crane accomplishes the
same thing that blocking and editing do
for other courtroom scenes it allows the
camera to move between several different
perspectives within a large courtroom
but instead of a cut it bridges those
perspectives by moving the camera the
crane gives these scenes so much energy
in depth it has the ability to show the
full extent of the courtroom
and during the show's most intense
moments the crane follows suit by moving
more quickly between characters the
crane acts as an all-seeing eye that can
tap into any part of the court
and because it's a mini-series the show
has more time to devote to each aspect
of the courtroom plenty of time goes to
the jury the judge
and audience members like the goldmans
and the reporters but even then
capturing all those characters is still
a challenge
the show had to add a split screen to
cover all the reactions to the verdict
while the filmmaking style starkly
contrasts with the actual visuals from
the tv broadcast it better conveys the
average american's experience with the
oj trial
it dominated the news for months and
most people felt like the crane camera
in this scene they peered into every
detail of all the characters lives and
relationships
the people vs oj didn't need to
dramatize this pivotal cultural moment
it only needed to show the drama that
already existed the filmmaking in the
people vs oj shows the height a
courtroom scene can reach the criminal
justice system already conveys so much
human drama so turning them into
compelling cinema is only a matter of
packaging the individual moments and
making them legible to a viewer it's a
challenge but when it pays off
it pays off big courtroom scenes are
some of the most popular scenes in
movies and tv
there are thousands of completely
different scenes i could have looked at
but i do know they all have one thing in
common each has to address the same
problem how do you film such a large
space with so many different characters
in it
the solution will vary from scene to
scene but whether it's solved through
blocking framing or ambitious camera
work if they pull it off
it'll always be impressive so the next
time you sit down to watch a movie try
picking something with a courtroom scene
or even a large ensemble scene just to
see how they captured all the characters
in the room but with so many films to
choose from it's sometimes overwhelming
to decide what to watch so if you ever
find yourself struggling with what to
pick
try mubi a curated streaming service
where each and every film is hand
selected so you'll never waste time
looking for something great to watch
every day mubi premieres a new film
that's curated by their team they have
tons of timeless classics award-winning
masterpieces and festival fresh gems the
kind of films i definitely want to be
watching
for a film with a huge ensemble cast and
many large complex set-piece sequences
try watching richard kelly's southland
tales a sci-fi film that satirizes the
growing military industrial complex and
the infotainment industry this amazing
film is part of movie's collection of
films hand-picked for you
you can try mubi for free for 30 days at
mubi.com
now you see it that's mubi.com now you
see it for a whole month of great cinema
for free
a big thanks to mubi for sponsoring and
thanks to you our patrons for your
support
if you want to support our work directly
join our patreon thanks for watching